‏ ‏ja
[Silence]
ح
اوك
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر الله
الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد
ان اله الا الا
الله اشهد ان
محمد رسول الله
اشهد
ان
محمدا رسول
الله حي على الصلاه
[Silence]
ا حي على الصلاه
حي على
[Silence]
الفلاح حي على الفلاح
الله اكبر
[Silence]
لا اله
الا
[Silence]
الله ان الحمد لله ان الحمد لله نحمده
ونستعينه ونستهديه ونعوذ بالله من شرور
انفسنا ومن سيئات
اعمالنا من يهدي الله فهو المهتد ومن يضلل
فلا هادي له واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه والتابعين اما بعد
معاشر الموحدين عباد الله فان اصدق الكلام
كلام الله عز وجل وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى
الله عليه وسلم وان شر الامور محدثاتها
وان كل محدثه بدعه وان كل بدعه ضلاله وان
كل ضلاله في النار اسال الله العظيم رب
العرش العظيم بمنه وكرمه وعفوه ان يجيرني
واياكم منها انه ولي ذلك والقادر
عليه يقول الله سبحانه تعالى يا ايها
الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من نفس واحده
وخلق منها زوجها وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا
ونساء واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به
والارحام ان الله كان عليكم رقيبا ويقول
الله سبحانه وتعالى يا ايها الذين امنوا
اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون ويقول سبحانه
وتعالى يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله
وقولوا قولا سديدا يصلح لكم اعمالكم ويغفر
لكم
ذنوبكم ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا
عظيما اما
بعد
اليوم اليوم لا املك لكم الجديد انما
جئتكم
تذكره جئتكم بان ثمانيه لا بد منها على
الفتاه ولا بد ان تجري عليه
الثمانيه سرور وهم واجتماع وفرقه ويسر
وعسر ثم سقم وعافيه طبيعه الدنيا الا تصفو
لاحد طبيعه الدنيا انلا تصفو لاحد وان صفت
فلن يطول فلن يطول صفاؤها
متغيره متقلبه متلونه سريعه الحوادث
والمفاجات والعاقل يتوقع فيها ما لا
يتوقع ويتوقع حوادثها بالحزم والعزم
والعمل بعد التوكل على الله عز وجل بل ان
الشر في الدنيا يكاد يكون اكثر من
الخير او كما قيل الخير لا ياتيك متصل
والشر يسبق سيله المطره يقول سبحانه
وتعالى ونبلوكم بالشر والخير فتنه والينا
ترجعون ويقول سبحانه وتعالى لقد خلقنا
الانسان في كبد اي اعلم ايها المسلم لا
تعتقد ان تصفو لك
الايام لا تعتقد ان تصفو لك الايام لا
تعتقد انك تتنعم في د ابتلاءات او
امتحانات او عثرات او صدمات او
كربات هذه كلها
اركان اساسيه من اركان هذه
الحياه الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
‏things happiness
distress gathering separation
eas sickness and will
being those a things
are a
man man
‏to
[Silence]
‏and
ration must
expect
life
expect expect the
uned الله سبحانه وتالى
‏and where the
name
from
ander
come as
‏down
ev
before and الله سبحانه وتالى say we will
test you ev and good as a trial and us
and to us you will be return الله سبحانه
وتالى says indeed we
have in constant
struggle no one is exempt
‏no
from do not
days for you
constantly do not that you enjoy without
without
trials shs distresses
اشن في تفاسيرهم للايه لقد خلقنا الانسان
في كبد اي ان الانسان خلق يكابد الشر على
السراء والصب على الضراء ولا يخلو من
احدهما ويكابد مصائب الدنيا وشدائد الاخره
ولا راحه له الا في الجنه
لقد خلقنا الانسان في
كبد الله سبحانه
وتالى man is to
exp
andle could more
الله سحانه
وتالى and testest tri
and another
جنه
rest
جنه اتعلم متى تصب لك
الايام عن انس رضي الله عنه قال قال لما
ثقل النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم جا يتغشاه
الكرب فقالت فاطمه رضي الله عنها واكرب
ابتاه فقال ليس على ابيك كرب بعد
اليوم فلما مات قالت يا ابتاه اجاب ربا
دعاه يا ابتاه جنه الفردوس ماواه يا ابتاه
الى جبريل
نعاه قال ليس على ابيك كربا بعد اليوم عند
وفاته صلى الله عليه وسلم تصفو لك الايام
حين وفاتك على
الايمان تصل
حياتك بالايمان بالقدر خيره
وشره تصب حياتك حياتك بالتسلح بالقناعه
والرضا بما كتبه الله لك تصفو حياتك
باليقين ان هذه
ثانيه وما عند الله خير
وابقى
days انس رضي الله
عن صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
عل said
‏so
death صل الله علسلم means is dist
father the days
الله
ev
and الله سبحانه وتالى
سبحانه
[Silence]
وتعالى ومن عجيب ما
قرات يقول المق في كتابه نفح الطيب عن
الخليف الاموي القوي عبد الناص الاندلسي
والمتوفى سنه 350
للهجره يقول وجدت في كتاباته انه عد
الايام التي يعتقد انه ارتاح
فيها حكم 56 سنه عبد الناصر الملك عبد
الناصر
الاندلسي يقول فلما عدت هذه الايام وجدتها
14 يوما فقط من 56 سنه
فيقول المقري في حاشيه ان هذا الملك عبد
الناصر الذي ملك عصره
ووقته دون في ك كتاباته ان لم تصف له
الايام الا 14 يوم من 56
سنه فيقول فسبحان العزه القائمه والمملكه
الدائمه لا اله الا
‏very
inter
k عبدناصر
was in his writing hand heed 56 years
ring his time and he was w down thear
the days had nole no pain and he was
rested
‏days 14
days
asain only 14 days
was was
the and
بارك الله لي ولكم في القران العظيم
ونفعني واياكم بما فيه من الايات والذكر
الحكيم اقول ما تسمعون واستغفر الله لي
ولكم فاستغفروه انه الغفور الرحيم
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام
على المبعوث رحمه للعالمين سيدنا محمد
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك عليه وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين اللهم وارضى عنا وعنهم
اجمعين
الرضى بقضاء الله خيره وشره هو من اعظم
المقامات ودرجات
الايمان انه الصب على حل ومر
القضاء الفرح
والترح السعاده
والشقاء الصفو والكدر التعلق باحبابنا ثم
وفاتهم الرخاء والشده النعماء
والضراء سعه الرزق وضيق حال الصحه
والعافيه
والمرض فاللهم ارضنا بما قسمته لنا لنكن
اسعد الناس لذلك كان من هدي النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم بل من ان بل من دعائه في
الحديث قال عجبا لامر المؤمن ان امره كله
خير وليس ذلك لاحد الا المؤمن ان اصابته
سراء شكر فكان خيرا له وان اصابته ضراء
فكان خيرا
ل
sit الله الرض بالقدر خيره وشره
‏and is not
[Silence]
easy سبحانه وتالى
ونبلوكم بالشر والخير
فتنه الله
[Silence]
‏from
given all
tri
اللهث صل الله عليه وسلم
صل الله عليه
وسلم said that does
any
this
any he
said
be for
[Silence]
اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد في الاولين
وصل وسلم على سيدنا محمد في الاخرين وصل
وسلم على سيدنا محمد في كل وقت وحين اللهم
صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد حتى ترث الارض ومن
عليها وانت خير الوارثين اللهم اعز
الاسلام والمسلمين واعلي رايتي الحق
والدين المبين اللهم يا ربنا ويا مولانا
ويا سميع الدعاء يا ذا المن والعطاء يا ذا
الجلال والاكرام يا حي يا قيوم يا من تسمع
دعائنا وترى مكاننا وتعلم سرنا
وعلانيتنا اللهم ابرم لنا وابرم لهذه
الامه امرا رشدا تعز فيه
ويهدي ويهدى فيه عاصيك وتذل فيه عدوك
ويعمل فيه بطاعتك اللهم انا نتوجه اليك
ونسالك باحب الاسماء اليك ونحن نؤمن انك
السميع المجيب القريب اللهم اصلح احوالنا
واحوال المسلمين اللهم اصلح احوالنا
واحوال المسلمين في كل
مكان في غزه والسودان وكل بقاء الارض يا
رب العالمين اللهم ففع عن اخواننا ظلم
المعتدين وادفع عنهم كيد الغاصبين اللهم
احفظهم بما تحفظ به اوليائك اللهم تقبل
شهدائهم اللهم ارحم موتاهم اللهم احفظهم
من بين ايديهم ومن خلفهم وعن ايمانهم وعن
شمائلهم برحمتك يا رب العالمين اللهم اجعل
هذا المجتمع سخاء رخاء امنا مطمئنا وسائر
بلاد المسلمين اللهم اعطنا سؤلنا و نعوذ
بك من شرورنا ونعوذ بك من شرور انفسنا
وسيئات اعمالنا اللهم تجاوز عنا السيئات
اللهم تجاوز عنا السيئات وتحمل عنا
التبعات اللهم اجزي والدينا عنا خير
الجزاء وبارك لهم في اعمالهم واعمالهم
واختم لنا ولهم بخاتمه الاحسان اللهم ومن
توفيته منهم فارحمهم واغفر لهم وافسح لهم
في قبورهم مد بصرهم اللهم صل وسلم على
سيدنا صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا محمد واله
وصحبه وسلم اللهم احينا على ملته اللهم
احينا على سنته وامتنا على ملته واوردنا
حوضه واكتب لنا شفاعته يا رب
العالمين اللهم اجز سيدنا محمد صلى الله
عليه وسلم عنا خير ما جزيت نبيا عن امته
اللهم اجز سيدنا محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
عنا خير ما جزيت نبيا عن امته عباده الله
ان الله يامر بالعدل والاحسان وايتاء ذي
القربى وينهى عن الفحشاء والمنكر والبغي
يعظكم لعلكم تذكرون واخر دعوانا ان الحمد
لله رب
العالمين الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان
لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمد
رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر
لا اله الا
الله استقيم اعتدل
استووا سووا الصف سد
الخلل الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين اذا
السماء انفطرت واذا الكواكب
انتثرت واذا البحار فجرت واذا القبور
بعثرت علمت
نفس ما قدمت
اخرت
يا ايها
الانسان ما ضرك بربك
الكريم الذي خلقك فسواك
فعدلك في اي
سوره ما
شاء
ركبك كلا بل تكذبون بالدين
وان عليكم
لحافظين كراما
كاتبين يعلمون ما
تفعلون ان الابرار لفي نعيم
وان الفجار لفي
جحيم
يصلونها يوم الدين وما هم عنها بغائب
وما ادراك ما يوم الدين ثم
ما ادراك ما يوم
الدين يوم لا تملك نفس
لنفس
شيئا والامر يومئذ
لله الله اكبر الله
ا سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
والسماء والطارق
وما ادراك ما
الطارق
النجم الثاقب ان كل نفس
لما عليها
حافظ
فلينظر
الانسان
مما خلق خلق مما
دافق يخرج من بين الصلب
والترائب
انه على رجعه
لقادر يوم تبلى
السرائر فما له من
قوه ولا ناصر
والسماء اذا الرجع والارض ذات
الصدع انه
لقول
فصل وما هو
بالهزل
انهم
يكيدون
كيدا واكيد
كيدا فمهل
الكافرين
امهلهم رويدا
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
يا
سلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام
علكه السلام
[Silence]
عل ‏in after
come
sisters there is there
isil nothing come if you
come come
us come
[Silence]
‏some
شا ان شاء الله
[Silence]
‏k
ا
[Silence]
‏ja